all right buffy
yeah buffy uh which hero where are you
from originally middletown ohio
ohio and tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents when you were
young you grew up with both parents good
childhood
pretty all-american midwest childhood
good
large key kid what kind of kid were you
in high school
pretty popular cheerleader track swim
team
skating and you graduated high school
yes and then what happened after after
that i went to college
i had a son when i was 17. i was a
senior in college
i mean i'm sorry senior in high school
and
everybody told me i wouldn't finish
college because of that and so i'm
pretty stubborn and
i finished college good for you that's
great
and uh where'd your life go after after
college
um well i was a poly sci major i have a
bachelor's degree in political science
i got accepted to law school but i had
done a summer
internship at capitol records
the year before i graduated and they
offered me a full-time position
it was um the early 90s you moved up you
moved to la
la at some point or um i was out here on
the summer internship
just at capitals between my junior
senior year in
college and i was supposed to go to law
school
but they offered me a full-time position
here so i
brought my son and we moved out here
and i started at capital records in 91
jewish and uh about six
to 12 months after i started i worked in
the publicity department where we were
hard pitching singles to the right radio
station still
and then uh napster came
and pretty major pretty much made my job
you know
obsolete um when everything went digital
so i ended up going with a an attorney
that left
capital he started a private um adoption
attorney um law firm
and i went to work with him and did
private adoptions for like
10 years well
i modeled when i was young and i started
modeling around
12 years old and i went to barbazon and
all that stuff but
i was with an agency agency out of
middletown
and he used to take groups of girls
backstage to concerts he
always had cocaine and pretty girls with
him and
pretty much got him in anywhere and
i think i went to my first backstage
experience with motley crew
and ozzie and i was like 15 i think
i partied with motley crue pretty heavy
one of the one other
roadies like fell in love with me and it
was a whole thing
well for some reason like per capita so
to speak like middletown ohio has the
most beautiful women i've
yet to see anywhere like all together
and i had a 76 chevy van that i used to
pile about
10 girls in and we could pull up at any
concert anywhere and
get in you know we were um
so your first experience doing that was
actually with the modeling agency but
then after that i kind of just branched
out on my own i used to travel all over
with bands i went on tour with a couple
bands with iron maiden
i toured with metallica and ozzy
and that was before cliff burton died so
it was in the early days
they were opening for ozzie um
i was dating vivian campbell for a while
he was with ronnie james dio
at that point before def leppard um
i dated the driver from the outfield
like
i went all over the country
and canada i guess and uh what does a
15-year-old girl backstage
end up doing um a lot of drugs a lot of
sex
a lot of just wild parties that's what
everyone imagines
it's just like everyone imagines yeah
interesting and uh so back to uh
back to la and uh after the
so you worked for a law firm for 10
years yes and uh
actively on drugs at that time too was
that right so
drugs came into your life around the uh
the groupie around 15 or so yeah
and you stuck with it harder drugs like
late
you know after i came out here i was
roommates when i moved
out here to work at capital with um this
one hit
what wonder band called jafria i don't
know if you i remember that remember
them or not
he was the drummer for them and he
played with ike and tina turner and
developed a cocaine habit with them with
ike turner
and played with the beach boys was on
that sub and all that
and he had i mean literally just about
every
famous rockstar and tv actor you could
think of that would buy drugs from him
and i moved in right you know into the
middle of that and that's when i started
doing
you know coke a lot so
i was snorting cocaine then and so
you still you you raised your son yes
the entire time he's 34 now he's 34 yeah
and then i also have a daughter um molly
that i got pregnant when i was here
um she's 30 she's turned 30 in february
she's an international model
so you've had a colorful life
yeah she actually had a she was married
and had a baby with
um the ceo of the home loan department
of jpmorgan
like this lady oversees like 2.9
trillion dollars in accounts
she had a child with her only sibling
her little brother
so you know she's very wealthy
from that they're not together anymore
of it
and so today you're living where today
i'm living
um well i tell my dad a lot that i'm
homeless because technically i don't
have a place in my name
he says you're not homeless you have a
bedroom here with everything you own
you're never home
but they're in ohio but i um i stay at
um a friend of mine has a house in
torrance that
i raised his um daughter with him
she's 18 her mom died when she was six
months old from a drug overdose
and so i'm pretty much like the only mom
she knows he's a pretty anti-social guy
so there's not a lot of people in her
life
so i try to stay close to her
but he has an obsession with me that's
not healthy
and so sometimes i stay in my car and i
you know park behind my brother's job
over here
so that i'm safe so at least when you're
in la you're homeless
recently yeah i have a
very recent ex-boyfriend that um
i'm 51 and he's 27
so and he's very abusive so i've
been going through a lot of drama with
that you know and
what is your drug today i used math
xanax yeah and back in the
that was the 80s that you were this is
the 90s is it the groupie thing
the group eating started in the 80s but
the heavy drugs started
in the 90s what drugs were popular back
in the 80s and 90s i mean i was snorting
cocaine
and just about anything you know
so as a homeless woman today
you're you're supporting yourself how um
well i get disability but that's only
a little bit of money but i am shoplift
a lot
so you know people tell me certain
things that they want and
i boost them yeah and there's uh
what are they called the people who buy
from the
boosters the fans the fences yes
yeah um i decided very early
out here in my drug addiction that i
wasn't going to be a prostitute
i'm not promiscuous and um
you know i'm very selective as far as
that goes so
i had to come up with some kind of
hassle i've sold drugs you know
broker drugs between people and i
wouldn't call myself a drug dealer but
in the middle man type of thing and
you're surviving
i'm surviving day to day i have a little
dog
usually he would be with me but he's not
today
what what's been the lowest point of
your life
i would say um
well it wasn't just one event but like
the last two years i my daughter was
i had a 19 year old daughter that was
killed in a car accident two years ago
and i lost both of my dogs that year too
and
i met this guy this abusive boyfriend at
that time
and so it was kind of the perfect storm
for him to just like
move in and he's really done a number on
me like emotionally
and confident wise and self-esteem
and physically and you know all of that
yeah that makes sense abuses of any sort
is
excuse me abuse of any sort it's got to
be terrible to go through yeah it's
really bad
what was the best time of your life um
this period
i've had a lot of them i've had it
sounds like it you know
i've had a lot of them
my childhood was really really good i
had good people i'm still friends with
the same people that i've known
my whole life i'm jewish but i went to
catholic school for 12 years and there
was only
60 people in my homeroom and i went to
school with those 60 people
for 12 years so they're still in my life
to this day most of them and you know
i look back on those times and they were
good
i i love the book to kill mockingbird it
reminds me of my hometown
yeah and your kids are doing well
right your kids are great and they
know that you're living like this i
don't know if my daughter
really understands that i'm you know
technically homeless um my son does more
so
but um she's fragile that way
you know like it would hurt her
you know even though she could fix it
like that but
i would never ask and
so it's kind of like the big white
elephant i don't see her a lot she
travels all over the world with her
daughter all the time and
you know she lives like a jay-z and
beyonce life
type of thing can i ask you to share one
of your one of your groupie stories
when you were younger so i'm just going
to tell you
like how it came to be sure okay sure
so um ozzy was coming
aussie and metallica metallica was a
fairly new band
they were opening for ozzy i was going
to see ozzy i had a mad crush on jakey
lee
their guitar player and i was just
determined to meet him
um i was 17. i was like two months
pregnant with my son probably
and i took uh three of my other
girlfriends
liz amy and rebecca and we just pulled
it was an outdoor venue in cincinnati
called
river downs and we um
never went with tickets never went with
anything we just
went on strength that we would get in
somehow
so um all four of us girls were standing
by the gate
that where the buses were parked behind
and how are you dressed
um i remember wearing skinny jeans
actually they were popular then too
um skinny skinny jeans and a tank top
with a big thick belt and i had big hair
and all that good [ __ ] and some some
high-heeled boots or something
and uh it was really hot outside i
remember it was
like july or something and i was
having morning sickness because i was
pregnant so i had gone to the car
to just cool off in the air conditioning
for a minute and when i came back the
girls were gone
they and there was other another two
girls
and they said they had gone back with
metallica
and i'm like oh great whatever you know
so i'm standing there like waiting to
try to catch
somebody's attention that could get him
for me
and i see a you know one of the tour
buses
and like all the guys are standing in
the front of the tour bus like looking
up towards us
like what the hell so this guy comes off
the bus and he
ended up being the dr the bus driver he
um
came up to the gate and he said to me he
was like aussie wants to meet you
and i'm like me and he was like yeah he
goes he wants to meet you i'm like
okay cool like i was happy i'm thinking
jake i'm all jk lee i'm thinking jakey
he's going to be on this right
so we get on the bus we walk down and i
get on the bus
and the one thing i remember is there
was porn playing and i'd never seen a
porn movie before
and they were watching porn and it was a
bus full of guys
and uh it was randy castillo
ozzy some of the other
crew members or whatever and i forget
the other guy's name that played with
them but jakey lee was not there
and i was really bummed out and so they
were watching the porn and i'm just like
sitting there awkward
and then the bus driver went in the back
with ozzy and um they called me back
there
and he was like um ozzy doesn't cheat on
sharon
he said but he would love to see your
tits
and i was like really and he goes yeah
he's going to give you a front row seat
and a pass
he just wants to see your tits he's not
even going to touch him
and i'm like okay and so i did it
i flashed in my boobs and that was it he
didn't touch me he didn't say a word to
me he just went back to the front of the
bus
and then the driver took me he gave me
my ticket and my pass and then he took
me to try to find my friends with
metallica
and we ran into jakey lee and i was so
excited
and but he couldn't talk to me he was
with a girl or whatever so they ended up
walking me out to the front row and my
friends were out in the front row
already and metallica was getting ready
to come on
and uh they came out metallica came out
and you know how they banged their heads
or whatever in
those concerts well they were the only
three people my friends
that were banging their head in the
whole place nobody knew what to think of
metallica
because it was the first kind of thrash
metal experience you know
so i was embarrassed that they were
doing that but whatever
and they were obviously interacting with
my friends you could tell them they were
into my friends and everything and i'm
just like whatever
and so ozzy was they finished their uh
set
and someone came out to get my friends
and i'm like i'm not going anywhere i'm
going to watch
ozzie i want to see jakey lee right so i
stayed for the aussie set
and i gave jakey leah rose he put it on
the end of the guitar him and ozzy were
like hugging kept singing to me the
whole time it was really really fun
and then towards the end of the concert
they sent someone out to get me from
metallica
and i went backstage and uh i went into
metallica's dressing room
and they were just maniacs they were
kids then and they were throwing chili
everywhere
and they were just acting like idiots
like you know and i was not impressed at
all
and kurt hammett was really into my
friend rebecca they ended up having a
relationship after that
concert and um i was talking to this
guy a torment tour guy in there
and i was telling him how i wanted to
meet jakey lee and da da
he's like here i'm going to take you
where he's going to come through the
store at a certain time
and so i ended up getting to meet jk lee
i took pictures of me kissing him
sitting in between his legs on the tour
bus like this whole
picture montage that we did um but
nothing personal really and i ended up
driving james hatfield and two groupies
to a
a club in cincinnati after the concert
because the limo was full with the rest
of the band and my friends
so james and his two girls rode with me
to this he was an [ __ ]
and we went to this club and and so we
were at the club and
i wasn't feeling well so i was watching
lars play um
pool and there was this blonde guy the
one that had told me about jakey lee
who was eating nachos right and he
scooped up a big like
chip of of jalapenos right i'm like
what's this guy doing he's gonna like
burn
and i guess he'd never had him before or
something so he scoops this big chip in
and his whole face turns red and he
grabs his alcohol and he's drinking that
and that sets it on fire and then he's
just like freaking out and i'm just
laughing my ass off
that ended up being lars lifelong best
friend and drum tech
and we ended up engaged three months
later so oh really
yeah cliff died right after that in that
terrible accident in europe um and my
boyfriend was
also on the bus he broke a leg and
it was just uh a change in the times and
music at that time
so it was pretty exciting i went to the
washington dc to the monsters
uh ball or whatever with them right
before cliff died
it was a wild time it's like it blew up
after that
yeah and you were 15. no i'm 17. you're
17. i was 15.
i have you started molly trip yeah yeah
this
the groupie thing went out for how many
years for you
probably about from about 15
till all through college
pretty much so like 21 22.
then by the time i moved out here and
lived at that drummer's house
i had evolved you know i was kind of in
the
inner circle then so you know i had a
lot of really
influential friends back then
so but again i never knew when to stop
partying so
that kind of messed everything up but
the groupie thing only happened when you
were
a teenager um just like my teenage years
and
in the early 90s but when you came to
l.a you didn't really
follow back well i was roommates with
that guy and i mean i spent every friday
at the rainbow with him and sam kennison
and
randy castillo and like everyone you
know every friday like
we were doing lines in the kitchen of
the rainbow
you know it was a blast
but i was always one me and my roommate
were always the ones that were
staying up way past everybody else you
know what i mean like
that's defines i think the difference in
someone that's
an addict and not you know the party
never ends for us
so i don't know how much of a party it
is anymore
but and crystal meth is is your
addiction i got one personal and i was
like 30
years old so i was a little bit late
with that
um when you first get on crystal if
you've been on cocaine
and you feel almost cured because you
don't
you know your habit can go from 300 a
day to 10. yeah this a lot
yeah you don't need to use as much and
but i've had more problems legally
and what not on crystal than i have
ever had with code so you know
crystal's been horrible for me
yeah and do you blame la for any of your
downfall or
or is this just no direct life's a
wonderful place
yeah yeah i see a lot of comments on my
channel where people say oh ellie's a
pit and it's it's actually the same as
any other city it's just
it's the survival of the fittest so i
consider myself a fittest
yeah because i survived here like 30
years i've been to every state and i've
seen
destruction human just human
self-destruction just as much
there's much more cuts right than than
here because people are hungry
you name your state delaware north
dakota whatever they they have the same
problems
we do here they just they look different
because la is there's just more
opportunity to come
up and make money or you know
opportunity here than there is anywhere
else so
i don't know i don't know it's
um i like l.a yeah and i don't blame it
at all i wouldn't blame california for
anything
not at all what would you point a figure
at in terms of
why you're in the situation you are
today i mean your childhood seemed
pretty perfect
but there were drugs involved poor
choices just
my own poor choices my people pickers
broke
drugs selfishness
you know
and where do you see your life going now
i'm not sure
i'm getting my stimulus tonight at
midnight
because for some reason disability
people got theirs late
so i get it tonight and i want to go
back to ohio
so that might be good i want to get a
cova test before i go to my parents i've
had
several but i want to make sure before i
go around my parents are older
my dad's having hip surgery and he needs
help so
that's the plan yeah it seems like a
good plan
there's too many too many ways to
self-destruct here in l.a
oh for sure for sure not that a 15 year
old girl can't get in trouble in ohio
apparently she can't that's for sure
and with this colorful life you've had
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
not to have regrets and bring as true to
yourself as you can
sounds like you've done that yeah i have
all right buffy well thank you so much
for sharing your story awesome i wish
you the best of luck
back in ohio thank you thank you very
much
you